[MUSIC PLAYING]
PACO NATHAN: Welcome.
I'd like to welcome you
all to Understanding Human
Bias at Scale With Kubeflow.
And I'm really looking
forward to the presentation
that we've got in
store here today.
My name is Paco Nathan,
and it's a pleasure
to get to introduce a
couple of friends here.
Let me get the
right clicker going.
So it's a pleasure to introduce
Michelle Casbon and John
Bohannon.
I met Michelle years ago at
one of my favorite startups
in San Francisco from a
few years back, Idibon,
and definitely [INAUDIBLE] of
working in natural language
processing.
And now through
other conferences,
I know we've done some talks
and whatnot hosting before,
but now at Google,
working on Kubeflow.
Also, John, I've met
through another one
of my favorite startups in
San Francisco, Primer AI.
And John's been leading a
project called Quicksilver.
You may have seen a Wired
article about this last fall,
roughly--
Octoberish or so?
And anyway, we'll dig
into more details.
They can both talk
much more about that.
I've spent a long time
working in the field.
And MLP has been a
large part of my career.
Language has so much power.
There is, of course,
the famous truism
about the pen being
mightier than the sword.
Language has so much
effect for good and bad.
And we're going to dig into
how to process that at scale,
but also some of
the implications.
So, with that, let's go.
There is the Dory app.
If you're not familiar with
it, there's some instructions
up here about how to use
the app to put in questions.
So down toward the bottom
there, you see the blue circle.
It says Dory Q&A. So
you can use the app
to submit questions
during the Q&A.
We have a lot of time for that.
There's also, though, a
microphone right here.
It's up toward the
back of the second row
there, if you want to come
up and get on the mic.
I think, for what it's worth,
we can probably field questions.
Because I don't think
that we're recording.
So we can do that as well.
Now, without further ado, please
welcome Michelle and John.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHELLE CASBON:
Thank you, Paco,
for that warm introduction.
In terms of our
agenda today, we'll
start out by talking about
the problem of human bias--
what makes it so
difficult to tackle
and how we can use machine
learning to help out.
We'll take you through some
of the major challenges
that we faced and
how we used Kubeflow
to address those challenges.
And we'll close out by giving
you a real world example
of bias busting in action.
A quick note about the
images on this slide--
special thanks go out to
Ben Swanson and [INAUDIBLE]
for creating an AI
generated 3D model that
was built on Kubeflow.
It's a fractal that
uses the inverse of pi
as one of its parameters.
So file that away in your
brain, because you'll find out
the significance of that later.
Let's get started.
JOHN BOHANNON: OK, I'm going
to do an experiment with you.
So everyone, do me a favor
and close your laptops,
at least for five minutes.
Thank you.
All right, ready?
If you've done this experiment
before, if this looks familiar,
keep it to yourself.
Don't spoil the others.
It's a very powerful
effect when it works,
so I want everyone to
have this experience.
OK, here we go.
Ready?
A boy and his father
are in a car crash.
The father is killed instantly.
The boy is rushed
to the hospital
and prepped for surgery
with one of the best
surgeons in the country.
Lucky him.
Doctor arrives, sees the
boy on the table, and says,
I can't operate on this patient.
He's my son.
Now, when I first saw this
myself, a couple of years back,
I was absolutely stumped.
Like, my mind just raced
to explain the paradox.
I'm sure right
now in your minds,
you're coming up with
explanations for this.
So, who is the surgeon?
Michelle?
MICHELLE CASBON: There's a
simple explanation for this.
It's the mother.
JOHN BOHANNON: Raise
your hand if you've
seen this for the first
time, and you immediately
knew the mother was the answer.
One, two, three.
Three, OK.
That's a little bit
lower than average.
Typically, 85% of
people are stumped
by this, which means, I guess,
by extension, more than three
out of this room
typically get it.
But don't feel bad.
I was also totally
stumped by it.
Michelle was totally
You are just a good
learning machine.
You've been trained
your entire life
on a stream of
very, very good data
that supports the prior
that surgeons are men.
So that's cognitive bias.
The reason that felt
hard was because you
have cognitive bias.
We all do.
And so, the goal--
and we're going to
describe one of these--
is to find technologies
that can help
us identify these biases that we
have and help us reverse them.
So here's a system that's
built on human decisions.
So Wikipedia is an example
of a web scale system, where
it's really just amplifying
the individual decisions
of individual humans.
So what happens is all
those cognitive biases
in those brains get inherited
by the web scale system.
You just can't avoid it.
It ends up happening.
Let me give you some examples.
But before I do, I
just want to emphasize
the astounding thing
about Wikipedia
is that it works at all.
So I'm going to be pointing
out some well-known problems
with Wikipedia.
But that's by no
means a deal-breaker.
I use it every day, I'm sure
like most of you do as well.
It is the world's most important
first point of information
about most topics.
And yet, there's absolutely no
one in charge of this thing.
It's really just a big
volunteer effort-- millions
of people deliberating
with each other
to reach consensus on facts
about the world worth knowing.
So let me give you an example.
So if you've never heard
of Donna Strickland,
I hope that you'll
never forget her now.
So last year, she won the Nobel
Prize in physics for her work
on laser physics.
First woman to win this prize
in 55 years-- it's a big deal.
On the day it was
announced, the world
was astounded to discover that
she had no Wikipedia page.
She now has a very long,
very detailed Wikipedia page.
I can't even capture
the entire table
of contents on the screenshot.
You may be surprised to learn
that all that information
that you can now learn
about this person
did not appear overnight.
It is not the case that
she won the Nobel Prize,
and suddenly, there was
all this information
available that was really
significant and notable that
deserved a Wikipedia page.
It was always there.
Somehow, we just missed it.
Let me also point out
that on that very day,
this fellow won the
same prize with her.
This is her co-laureate.
He has a much less
detailed page.
But it has existed since 2004.
Let me show you an example of
a typical web page, a Wikipedia
page about a scientist.
I found this guy at
random, just using my data.
Totally typical meat and
potatoes Wikipedia page
about a scientist--
is based at some
research institute,
studies a certain topic,
and has some public impact.
There are citable,
reputable news sources
about this person and his work.
And so you get a Wikipedia page.
Totally normal, nothing
controversial here.
Now, in the same query where
I found him in my data,
I found a colleague
of his, who works
on almost the same thing--
very similar topic,
public health.
There's actually more to say
about this colleague of his.
I would love to show it
to you, except it's pretty
hard to fit it on the screen.
Her name is Ami Zota.
And the reason it just
won't fit on the screen
is because there's
this huge warning
banner stuck on her page.
This is basically
the process by which
Wikipedia pages get deleted.
So the community basically--
first, it starts
in the talk page,
where they say this person
just isn't that notable.
Then someone decides
to slap a big banner,
and eventually, essentially,
this gets fixed,
or the page gets taken down.
So there's no bad guy here.
There's no evil
group of people out
to delete scientists
from Wikipedia.
These are good
citizens just trying
to keep Wikipedia's
standards high.
But the problem is, it's
a subjective decision.
How do you decide
whose page is not
worthy of the world knowing?
You just have to use your gut.
And that's just an invitation
for your cognitive biases
to have an effect.
So I also want to show you an
example of the opposite effect.
How many of you have
ever heard of Sting?
Now, take your hand down if
that Sting was the singer.
Anyone still have their hand up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JOHN BOHANNON: Oh, very strong.
Very strong.
OK.
I want you to keep that in mind.
But here's an example
of a scientist
who has the longest and most
detailed Wikipedia page of all.
So there is no female scientist
who even comes close to this.
And it's not because it's
the most important scientist
in the world, or her
work is that important.
It's because her life intersects
with a topic that people just
pay a huge amount
of attention to,
namely the post
9/11 war on terror.
So this is just to show you
that overattention can also
be a result of cognitive bias.
Now, here's your favorite Sting.
Her page, the one I just showed
you, was 10,000 words long.
This one's 20,000 words long.
And in fact, of all the
occupations of people,
the occupations that have by far
the most attention about whom
the most details are kept on
Wikipedia, are updated the most
zealously, so that every
little micro detail that you
can update them on gets updated,
are definitely not scientists.
It's professional wrestlers.
And it's not because
professional wrestling
is far and away the most
important thing about people
or the kind of people that
you most need to know about.
That's Wikipedia for you.
It's a crowdsourced
knowledge base.
So the things we care
more or less about
get diminished or magnified.
It's an imperfect
lens on our world.
And that's OK.
But wouldn't it be great to
be able to map out this bias?
Before we can fight against
our cognitive biases,
you have to know
even what they are.
How do we get the
tools to do this?
So Michelle and I have
talked about this a lot.
If you're going to build
a machine learning system,
it's really helpful to
imagine you're the machine.
That's really the
best first step.
Imagine you're the computer.
What is your task?
So let's say that
you're the computer,
and your task is to identify
all of the people who
should be on Wikipedia
and those about whom
we're paying more attention
than the citations deserve.
Where would you even begin?
MICHELLE CASBON:
Well, first, you'd
have to look at all the
existing Wikipedia pages.
There are 5 million of them.
JOHN BOHANNON: In English, yes.
MICHELLE CASBON:
News articles are
being published every day,
so thousands of news articles
on a daily basis.
You'd have to read all of those.
JOHN BOHANNON: Hundreds of
thousands, in English alone.
MICHELLE CASBON: Come up with
the important information
in one set that doesn't
exist in the other set--
kind of impossible for a human.
JOHN BOHANNON: And do the diff.
MICHELLE CASBON: That's a lot.
JOHN BOHANNON: So yeah, really,
really sucky task for a human.
We have on order of a million
volunteers trying to do this.
It's the largest such effort
in the world and totally
not keeping up with it.
They've measured the
latency, for example,
when huge things
happen in the world,
and they're printed
in newspapers.
How long does it take before
they arrive on Wikipedia?
It's long.
It takes a long time.
Unless it's about professional
wrestling, in which case,
it's instantaneous.
So this is the kind
of data that we need.
So this is an actual
screenshot of the data
that comes from this
system called Quicksilver.
So I'm at a startup just up
the street called Primer.
And what this thing is doing
is it's reading all the news
in a few different languages.
But everything I'm going to talk
about today is about English.
And it also reads
Wikipedia, of course.
And what it's doing
is it's extracting
facts about the people and then
writing summaries about them.
And so this is what we need.
So how many of these
people actually
are described in Wikipedia?
So now, what you have
is a ranked list, right?
You can sort how much did we
learn about these people--
in this case, scientists, in
this case, female scientists.
How much did we
learn automatically
with an AI system from the
news, versus how much is
known about them in Wikipedia?
Ta-da.
Hardest problem
effectively solved.
So when we first started
talking about this,
when we got a lot of coverage
in Wired, for example,
last year, we were--
we being Primer-- were
really, really proud of this.
Pretty much smug, because we
only had tens of thousands
of people being tracked with on
order of hundreds of thousands
of news docs.
And we did it from
static JSON ML files,
so really, really not scalable.
And so since then,
we've basically
been getting the
system onto Kubernetes
and trying to make it
actually work at scale.
And we immediately started
to run into problems.
And Michelle came and
gave us a consultation.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Yeah, so when I first
got my hands on
Quicksilver, I set out
to look at the
existing architecture,
figure out how it was
built. It was originally
a set of separate
pieces, running
in a hand-rolled
Kubernetes cluster on AWS.
And I had one key
question for John.
As you scale the number of
people you were looking at,
what kind of performance
were you seeing?
JOHN BOHANNON: Bad.
[LAUGHS]
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
so it seemed fine
with just the
first few thousand.
But as you started to
grow to Wikipedia scale,
you ran into challenges.
This is a very familiar problem.
You have this handcrafted,
artisanal ML system
that's been meticulously
sculpted for solving
a tangible problem.
You have a relational
backend, a document store,
a caching layer, and a
monolithic coordinates
between all of those pieces.
With that as a starting
point, the first thing we do
is forklift it into GCP.
Some of this was easy.
For example, moving the
Kubernetes manifests onto GKE
was straightforward.
Thankfully, you were
already running Kubernetes.
And we moved some of those
application config files
into config maps and database
credentials into secrets.
We even moved the document
store from Elastic
into Cloud Storage.
Elastic was overkill
for this application.
So we used the simplest
storage we could find.
But other things
were a bit harder.
When you stand up
your application,
what's the first thing it does?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah, so step
one, hit postgres and talk
to the knowledge base.
And that's also step n.
It basically has to iterate
back and forth, back and forth,
back and forth with SQL calls.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
so I noticed that.
Actually, moving the data
from postgres into Cloud SQL
was just delightfully
straightforward.
But connecting to it
was another story.
So if you haven't
used Cloud SQL before,
if you want to
run an application
inside of Kubernetes
Engine, you need
something called a
sidecar that gives you
a proxy, a connection proxy.
And what it does is it
creates a network tunnel.
It continuously refreshes
your SSL certificate.
It can be a bit
tricky to set up,
but once you get it
running, you generally
don't have to think about it.
OK, so now that we have
it running in GCP, great.
Now you have two problems.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yay.
MICHELLE CASBON: Your
application runs poorly
on two different clouds.
JOHN BOHANNON:
Mission accomplished.
Yeah, so it is still
directionally correct,
though, because although
we're talking about scientists
and Wikipedia as a
motivating example,
we're actually
building products.
So what our customers
want is a system
that you can just feed in
natural language documents.
It will automatically
stand up a knowledge base
and update it, as it learns
things from those documents,
and then describe itself
in natural language
ports of some kind, and
always comparing itself
to some source of truth.
So that's the generalizable
system we're going for.
And so we want this thing
to be able to deploy
on any kind of cloud
or on-prem, actually.
A lot of customers need
this to work on-prem.
So if we can make it
work in both AWS and GCP,
it's definitely a step
in the right direction.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK,
so the primary team
did this the hard way.
Sometimes a monolith is OK.
But in your case,
having a design template
would have helped you build
a scalable application
from the beginning.
JOHN BOHANNON: OK, but just
note that Kubeflow did not exist
when this project started.
MICHELLE CASBON: Yeah,
so it's not too late.
Kubeflow can still help.
So let's look at how.
I prepared a
recording for today.
What we'll be doing is
spinning up clusters
and watching nodes
scale up and down
and performing training,
which is about as
exciting as watching paint dry.
So we'll skip over some
of those boring parts,
and we'll start by looking
at our empty GCP console.
So from a blank slate,
the question is always,
where do you begin?
Primer was brand new to GCP.
So we started with an empty
project, and what we need
is a way to create a fresh
cluster from scratch.
Well, good news.
There's an app for that.
It's called Click to Deploy.
And if you go to
deploy.kubeflow.cloud,
you'll find this form.
We need a couple of
pieces of information.
You have a project name.
We need to give our
deployment a name.
Let's call it Kubey.
JOHN BOHANNON: Let's.
MICHELLE CASBON: Give it
our OAuth credentials.
If you're not sure
to create those,
there are instructions
on the left.
And that's it.
We're using the very
latest version of Kubeflow.
It was just released last week.
So how many people here
have used Kubeflow before?
OK, of those, who
installed it themselves?
OK, all right, one person.
So you understand
exactly how hard this is.
This application is
getting rid of all
of that hard work for you.
What it's doing is
spinning up a GKE cluster.
It's setting up the project,
creating service accounts,
enabling APIs, and installing
all the Kubeflow components.
And you can watch those install.
It takes about five minutes
to get to this point,
where you have
everything running.
But also, it gives
you a public URL.
That takes about another
10 to 15 minutes.
And once that's up
and running, you
can go into your Services tab,
find your ingress service,
and just click on the
link that it gives you.
So what you have now, this
is your central dashboard,
and this is the
entry point into all
of the sort of Kubeflow UIs.
Well, that's the
official installation.
That's what you get if
you just use the app.
But I always do one extra
little step for my clusters.
I'm going to show you the sort
of secret backdoor feature.
It's one of my
favorite GCP features.
It's called autoprovisioning,
and it's a GKE beta feature.
So if you run this command,
you can specify maximum limits
for CPU and memory.
And what it does is when you
run jobs on your cluster,
it will scale the
number of nodes
up and down, based on the
requirements that are there.
So this takes about
five minutes or so.
But once we have
it up and running,
we don't have to think about
the size of our cluster.
So if we take a look
at the number of nodes
that we start out with, we've
essentially created a baseline.
We have a node pool
with two nodes, which
is enough to run all
the base components
and a few extra jobs.
So we're starting off
with just these two nodes.
OK.
So now that we have our
running installation,
what exactly does that mean?
So we just saw at
deploy.kubeflow.cloud--
if you want to try it
yourself, you can go there--
we had a number of
different components.
I'm just going to refer
to them as ingress.
There's a lot going
on behind the scenes.
We'll talk a little
bit about it later.
But ingress essentially
gives us that public IP.
And it's a single ingestion
point into our cluster.
It handles all of the auth, so
that nothing inside the cluster
has to think about it.
From there, we saw
the central dashboard.
And that gives us access to
all the other dashboards.
We have some for training,
some for running our pipelines.
Argo is the workflow engine
that powers pipelines.
Katib is a way of performing
hyperparameter tuning.
And then we also
have a notebook hub.
We have operators for running
training jobs in a distributed
way.
Argo helps us run our pipelines.
Katib helps us with
hyperparameter tuning.
And once we have our trained
models, we can serve them.
We have a few components
that help with that--
TensorFlow for TensorFlow
models and Seldon
for any Python model.
So at this point, we have
a blank Kubeflow slate.
Now how can I take an existing
application, Quicksilver,
and run it in Kubeflow?
So we can take your
existing manifests
and apply them to our cluster,
but not from a terminal.
What's the language that your
application is written in?
JOHN BOHANNON: Python.
MICHELLE CASBON: And
what about the rest
of the code base at Primer?
JOHN BOHANNON:
Pretty much Python.
MICHELLE CASBON:
It's all Python.
So you have all this
Python expertise.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah.
MICHELLE CASBON:
Let's use Python.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yay.
MICHELLE CASBON:
So this is what it
looks like to run our
monolith on Kubeflow.
We create a pipeline, and each
step is one of our components.
Let's see it in action and run
our monolith as a pipeline.
So start by going to
the pipelines dashboard,
and there's nothing there yet.
So we can upload a file and
create a pipeline using Python.
We have a few Python files here.
We'll look at the
monolith version.
And we start off by
importing our libraries
and defining the image
that we want to use.
And we set up two
distinct steps,
and we compile those
into a pipeline.
We're using this
pipeline decorator,
and we set up each step in the
order we want them to run in.
And then those
last three lines is
what compiles it
into an archive file
that we can then upload
into our cluster.
So we have our caching
layer, our monolith step,
and if we just compile
it as is, we'll
get a file that we
can bring into our UI.
What's inside that file, this
is Argo workflow definition.
So it's really
detailed and long.
You can open up that file.
It's all text.
It's not binary.
But you can upload
it directly as is.
JOHN BOHANNON: And you
didn't have to write it.
MICHELLE CASBON: You
You could use the Pipelines SDK.
So if we upload it, we can
see a visual representation
with two steps, caching
and then our application.
And if we want to run
it, we'll give it a name.
And this will actually
execute it on our cluster.
So we can view it
executing from this UI,
including accessing
all the logs.
We'll see what that looks like.
So our redis container,
it's pulling the image.
It's creating it.
And then it sets
up our application.
JOHN BOHANNON: This
is my favorite part.
I think this UI is
really beautiful.
MICHELLE CASBON: So
there we have it.
Oh, this is the bare minimum.
So at this point, Quicksilver
can handle daily workloads
involving scientists.
But for a generalizable
solution, what kind of scale
do you need?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah,
so, I mean, if we're
going to power all of
Wikipedia editing for anyone
in the world who wants to track
some entity, some Wikipedia
page, and have the
news automatically
be processed and give them
updates on what's new,
then definitely, we're
talking about web scale.
MICHELLE CASBON: So there's
no getting around it.
I hate to break
this to you, but you
need to carve up your monolith.
JOHN BOHANNON: No, don't
carve up my monolith.
MICHELLE CASBON:
So this is where
Kubeflow components can help.
This is what that looks like.
It's a longer pipeline now.
It's split up into
smaller pieces.
You have a data ingestion phase.
And once your data is there,
you can begin training.
And you can do that in
parallel, separately.
Once that training is complete,
you can serve those models,
and then stand up your web app.
Well, that's the concept.
How do we actually
implement that?
Let's kick it up a notch.
How can I take an existing
pipeline and make it better?
OK, audience question-- what's
the best tool for quickly
iterating on a Python file?
What are some of
your favorite tools?
AUDIENCE: Jupyter.
MICHELLE CASBON: Jupyter
notebooks, excellent answer.
JOHN BOHANNON: [LAUGHS]
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
Where did the mouse go?
OK.
So we'll start by going
to the Notebooks tab.
You read my mind.
OK, so what's better than
hosting your notebooks locally
and competing with all
of your open browser tabs
for resources?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHELLE CASBON: Running it
on someone else's resources,
that's right.
That way, you have room
for all the cat memes.
So what we're doing here is
Kubeflow provides this spawner,
and we can spin up our very
own JupyterHub instance.
This takes about two
or three minutes.
But this is all running
inside our cluster.
So we can access it locally.
We connect right here, and
we have our own instance.
So we'll go and we'll find
our microservices notebook.
Upload our own file.
JOHN BOHANNON: It is also really
great for reproducibility.
I can point you at
the exact notebook
where I ran everything.
You can see how I got it wrong.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so,
fun fact about notebooks.
The very first time
I saw a notebook,
I was in Paco's workshop.
This was probably 2013, 2014.
I don't even know
if he knows this,
but I learned everything I
know about notebooks from Paco.
That was the very beginning.
So you're seeing
this in action here.
OK, so this is our microservices
version of Quicksilver.
The first thing
we do, we're just
using a stock TensorFlow image.
So we're going to install
Kubeflow pipelines
on top of it, and then we
import those libraries.
We define some static variables,
so which images we want to run,
which versions.
And then we retrieve
our database credentials
from secrets.
That way, nothing is
hardcoded in GitHub anywhere.
And then we define
each of our steps.
We ingest our data
first, and then we train.
And this step is
kind of interesting.
It's doing some unique things.
So we're making
requests for resources.
We're saying that we want
a couple of CPU cores
and 32 gigs of RAM.
We're grabbing those
database credentials,
and then we're
adding our sidecar.
This is what gives us the
connection to Cloud SQL.
This was a brand new feature.
Thank you to [INAUDIBLE]
for committing that
two weeks ago, just in time
for me to get this prepared.
This is one of my
favorite things.
So this training step, because
we're requesting resources just
for this one step, that
means that we don't need it
for the entire pipeline.
So being able to specify
it at a step level
is what helps us to
scale at our cluster.
So we compose our pipeline.
We define each of those
steps and the order
we want them to run in.
We generate our archive file
right here in the notebook,
and we can actually kick
it off from here as well.
So we have a link that brings
us directly to our Pipelines
dashboard.
And we can see our
pipeline running.
JOHN BOHANNON: Ta-da.
MICHELLE CASBON: So our data
ingestion ran just fine.
But our training job--
I know that's small.
It says this step
is impending state.
It's unschedulable,
insufficient memory.
JOHN BOHANNON: No.
Call DevOps.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK,
so what do we do?
Let's do some troubleshooting.
We'll drop down to
the container level.
Let's see what's going
on with our training pod.
We have a few more
details in here.
And it looks like, OK, so
we couldn't schedule it,
but TriggeredScaleUp.
This is a good sign.
This means that our
autoprovisioning is kicking in.
And because we only had
two nodes originally,
and we wanted more RAM
than was available,
we can see this happening.
If we go into the console, we
can see the nodes spinning up.
JOHN BOHANNON: DevOps
is already on it.
Didn't even have to call them.
Oh, DevOps.
MICHELLE CASBON: All via Python.
So that all happens
in the background.
And as soon as that
node becomes available,
that'll take a few minutes.
Our job will complete.
And then the rest of our
pipeline can finish running.
Because what's better-- having
a fact cluster up all the time
or having a fact cluster
up just for a few hours?
OK, so the cool thing is that
once that pipeline is done,
the nodes disappear.
So the node pool that was
stood up gets deleted.
And our application
is up and running.
OK, so I talked about
the ingress components.
And I told you there was kind
of a lot going on behind it.
One of the cool things about it
is that there's a reverse HTTP
proxy.
So we can just add a
route to our external URL
and navigate to
slash Quicksilver.
And we can actually see our
application up and running.
JOHN BOHANNON: Yay, there it is.
MICHELLE CASBON: All right.
So what has Kubeflow given us?
We've gotten portability,
so that we can
run on any Kubernetes cluster.
Kubeflow's entirely open source,
and it uses vanilla Kubernetes
APIs.
So as long as you're running
open source Kubernetes,
you can run Kubeflow on top.
That means you can run it
on another cloud, on-prem,
or even local.
There's no vendor lock in.
We've also gotten scalability.
So that means that our costs
can grow in line with our user
growth, and we can be very
fine grained about that.
And then we also
have composed ability
so that our ML design
can handle web scale.
As platforms like Kubeflow
make it easier and easier
to build ML applications,
it's our responsibility
to build ethical ML systems.
A revealing bias can have a
positive effect immediately.
Now that we have our
system up and running,
what can we expect to happen
when we ask Quicksilver what it
knows about a fellow speaker?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah, so when
I saw that login screen,
by the way, just like weeks ago,
literally, I was very excited.
And to test it out, we have been
actually taking the speakers
of this very event--
just little bits of information
about them, really--
just like name, employer--
as tuples, keywords
if you have them.
But really, it works just
with name and employer.
And feed them into the system,
and it reads all the news
for the past several
years at least.
And it tries to find
everything it can about them
and assemble together a profile.
And then it hits
Wikipedia, and it's
like, well, how much
do I know compared
to what Wikipedia knows?
And so yeah, we
actually, we found
someone who popped right to
the top when we ran this.
So she had been pretty quiet
in the news until mid-March.
March 14, in fact, is
when things just exploded.
And anyone know the
significance of March 14?
Pi Day, yes.
So there is an
engineer at Google,
named Emma, who calculated
31.4 trillion digits of pi,
breaking the world
record very easily.
And there was just a ton
of news coverage of this.
She did it on GCP.
It was a cloud computing feat.
And sure enough, as
journalists basically
did their job of describing
this scientific feat
and describing the
scientist behind it,
you started to learn
more and more about Emma.
Lots of little bits of string
that the AI system gathered
together in order to have
a bunch of cool things
to say about someone.
Now, this was
trained on Wikipedia.
So it's essentially
like, its model
of what counts as interesting
is everyone on Wikipedia.
So it's just finding facts
that kind of basically
are similar to that
and assembling them.
And can we run it?
Yeah, so this is us
actually getting her profile
from Quicksilver.
And ta-da she is at the top.
And this is what the
machine just like spat out.
Hey, there's Emma.
I know about her.
And if you have the job
of keeping Wikipedia up
to date with the latest
people in the world of science
and what they're up to and the
discoveries they're making,
this is the hardest step.
How would you even
have found Emma?
Unless you were literally
reading all the news every day
and just keeping track of every
single scientist ever mentioned
and then visiting Wikipedia
to find out what you missed,
that is like an impossible task.
So today, actually, as
of early this morning,
at night, this is now public.
So all of you can go
to that URL at the top,
quicksilver.primer.ai, and we
are just updating this everyday
automatically.
And so once upon a time,
what we were doing was,
I would generate these
spreadsheets of data
about scientists
using Quicksilver.
And then I would help
people who run editathons.
So that's basically,
you get a bunch people,
and you give them
pizza and beer,
and you edit
Wikipedia as quickly
as you can to improve it.
It's an editathon.
And it's really,
really hard work.
It's surprisingly hard work.
And just those
spreadsheets of data output
were incredibly useful.
That's what everyone said.
We ran them in New York,
London, Washington, DC.
And the feedback was
just very, very positive.
This kind of data
is what we need.
And then last week, we
actually had a editathon
just down the street, using
these completely generated
profiles.
Because one of the
pieces of feedback I got
was those spreadsheets of
data about people is handy,
but it's still
pretty hard to read.
What we really need
is to just have
the computer write the first
draft of the Wikipedia article.
Can you do that?
So we did it.
Now, essentially, you can
go here every single day,
and it will just
find people that it
has detected as having
lots of information
in public, citable sources,
where that information seems
to be missing from Wikipedia.
So now, anyone,
anywhere, anytime
has that first really hard
cognitive bias problem
of what to pay attention to
in the first place solved,
at least for scientists.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, so
is Emma on this list?
Does she have a page?
JOHN BOHANNON: Yeah, so I'm
very proud to say that Emma now
has a Wikipedia page.
And this is a good one.
So you remember I showed
you that Wikipedia page
of the scientist from Harvard?
It's kind of modest, no image.
This is a better page.
It's actually got more sources.
It's really well interlinked.
All those blue letters
are basically Wiki links,
embedding this page within
Wikipedia's Knowledge Graph.
That interlinking
is really important.
So this is a good page.
However, I kid you not.
Within two days of this
page getting created--
which, by the way,
was made by Jess
Wade, all credit due to her,
a collaborator and friend
based in the UK--
this started to appear in the
talk page of Emma's Wikipedia
page.
MICHELLE CASBON: OK, let's zoom
in on the logic behind that.
JOHN BOHANNON: This is how
the door gets cracked open.
This is the very beginning of
the process of deleting someone
from Wikipedia.
MICHELLE CASBON:
OK, so the reason
this person gave for
wanting to delete
Emma's page is they say that
the computation may be notable,
but that is not enough
by itself to make
the person who did it notable.
JOHN BOHANNON: So it's a
bit of a paradox, right?
If all you're famous for
is winning the Nobel Prize,
like really just the
one thing, it just
doesn't quite make the cut.
And again, these
are not bad actors.
These are just people, one of
the many, many volunteers just
trying to keep Wikipedia's
standards high,
but it's a hard, subjective task
to decide what the world should
and should not know about.
MICHELLE CASBON: Paco,
please join us on stage.
JOHN BOHANNON: So we're going
to do something with you
here now on this public
stage at a public event.
We're going to introduce to
you the first ever Notability
Award.
We call it the Kubey.
MICHELLE CASBON: A Kubey.
JOHN BOHANNON: And it
is given to a person who
has abundant, significant
information in public citable
sources about their
life and work.
It's a computationally
generated prize.
I think AI can start
giving prizes to humans
that it learns things about.
And the first ever Kubey--
PACO NATHAN: Thank
you very much.
JOHN BOHANNON: Goes to-- wait.
We don't know who won it.
No, it's not going to him.
MICHELLE CASBON: The very
first recipient of this award
is sitting amongst us today
right here in the audience.
Who could it be?
PACO NATHAN: So let
me open this up here.
JOHN BOHANNON: One of you.
MICHELLE CASBON: One of you.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MICHELLE CASBON: We will
invite you up to the stage.
PACO NATHAN: OK, I'm
going to rip this open.
This is a very exciting moment.
The first ever Notability Award
goes to the one, the only Emma
Haruka Iwao.
Please join us in [INAUDIBLE].
Emma, come on up.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]